[Music]
for some there's only one election issue
the brexit border separating them from
great britain
but there are other pressing concerns
even in unionist heartlands the
protocols bank has no doubt that but to
me the housing issue is the the biggest
household the biggest issue in this area
i like to say it's getting equal in
quality for both sides yes no yes and i
think the number one factor is
the living issue yeah the electric and
the gas what do they do for my community
they don't do that for my community they
only come around the door when they're
looking they're full
irish nationalists are poised for a
historic victory but shin feins michelle
o'neill can only become first minister
if unionists form a government with her
father martin mcgill fears more
political stalemate
he rebuked politicians at journalist
lira mckee's funeral for not coming
together sooner
why in god's name
does it take the death of a 29 year old
woman with her whole life in front of
her
the priest says political vacuums are
dangerous in northern ireland
i have to say my my blood would run cold
i would put it to strongly isn't that
with the idea of steel mitt
steel meat here has left us in some very
very dark places so if they're still
made that our politicians refuse to do
that then we
then they provide a grind where the
likes of those in organized crime gangs
will flourish
in the last stormont election the
democratic unionist party won 28 seats
shinfe and 27 but the dup is under
pressure over brexit
there are two more moderate parties the
ulster unionists and the nationalist
sdlp and alliance its middle ground vote
steadily increasing
freya mcclement's northern editor of the
irish times says a shinfi and win would
write a whole new chapter here it plays
into the question of a border pole a
unity referendum whether there should be
a united ireland because that's the
conversation that was put really firmly
on the agenda by brexit that
conversation is not going away and
you'll hear the dup very vocal on this
saying if there's a nationalist first
minister it brings that border pool
closer
brexit and the resulting border in the
irish sea have been political game
changers here one driving nationalist
demands for irish unity the other
fueling unionist fears about their place
in the united kingdom and that creates
the potential for this to be a defining
election
for a hundred years storm and elections
have been won by pro-british parties
victory for an irish nationalist party
holds out the prospect of real
constitutional change
david blevins sky news at stormont